thank everyone hi my name is suta Kansa
wha
I very appreciate reviewers and boaters
feel selected my proposal and today I'd
like to talk about comparison or pison
and all in just rambling on data
visualization so here's the agenda today
I compare them as language explain
differences between them in little
angling and data visualization on some
other cases before start let me
introduce myself
shortly after the English again my name
is Yuta comes over I'm from Tokyo the
scientist at Johnson Johnson technically
and my company is yongsan pharmaceutical
it's a pharmaceutical division of
Johnson Johnson and walk in Tokyo and I
analyze data for sales force
effectiveness and marketing and use our
and Python daily I mean I should I'm a
huge fan of opera and wine and I used
seven languages Japanese English German
for human and all pythons us speaker for
computers in Alan price when I first
done al then I also learned Python so I
came this Tuesday to Berlin for this
talk on this beautiful incredible
conference and actually I'm still be
suffered from jet lag so if I said there
anything wrong maybe it's because of jet
lag
and this is my second time in Berlin and
here I brought the do you know the app
called Foursquare or yeah do you know so
on this is my chickens in Germany since
2012 dry on 2 September 2019 as you can
see and Germany is to me one of the
favorite the holy destination but mainly
insults so I'm very glad to be here in
Berlin so let me take a quick survey so
if you use now however use out please
raise your hand
oh that's more than you expected
thank you - everybody thank you um both
oh thank you ok so um yeah I can assume
that tenure at least familiar with all
languages so now I get into main courses
first about differences and similarities
as long as all on Python differences all
is mainly used for statistical analysis
and is the reason the language is
created while Python is widely as you
know widely used in web application
system development are also in the
science sorry
and there may be answer things you might
you I mean Python misses might find a
little bit strange in how is one is that
and the use of the dots dots
sorry huh okay sometime notes are out in
names in our as you know but maybe I'm
it's a little bit different way to use
dots in Python but also in our index
starts at 1 not 0 as in Python here's
another but one of big difference for me
between our on Tyson
in our as most of you know operators and
functions are apply basically apply to
each element of vector while not in
Python so this is a simple example about
vector of X elements are want to see if
you want to squit square of each value
of x you know you can simply applied on
x oscilloscope to it which means the x
squared but if you did that in python
you get a type error it's not
implemented for the list then you need
to use a list comprehension or for loops
so this is a big difference and i was
supplied when start learning Python and
sometimes even today I struggle this
difference on the other hand now they
have many similarities as well they both
first appeared in early 1990s and took
about 10 years before their first major
conferences had been held constantly hmm
their major : clench stable versions
close three point six point one on say
point seven point four
both are dynamical typing and both have
the famous iris dataset do you know as
this said yeah everybody loves dead iris
so second about data wrangling here I
compare tie divorce in our on pandas in
Python tidy bus is metal idly that is a
collection of all packages for dead
science and it is created based on a
philosophy called tidy data I explain it
later
oh I tweaked it my and slide so on you
can find my name under the slide you
talk on the button and you can see my
slides on your desktop if you want and
in tidy bus one of the important feature
is a pipe operator here this one pass
and pass integrator and path end and
this is I think this is a unique
operator in tidy bus and this pipe
operator connector functions and let
data flow from one to the next function
as like us in method chaining in pandas
so what's tidy data here's a brief
description about that but then you
don't worry and if you don't understand
me neither so tidy data is data where
each variable forms a column and each
observation forms a row
definition actually definition of
variable and of the Bayesian is
depending on your data and your goal but
in this example the left table is not
tidy because week still one on week
though two should be there are different
time points and they should be value of
week like as in the right table so this
is a light this is the RS dead set in
case you don't know about that the
original iris dataset is not so tidy for
me
so it's because lengths and videos which
I included in the column should be
treated as value of dimension like the
blow so I want to clarify it how can I
do that in our on Python here left is a
code in all using 30 verse so you can
call our s did said maybe as you know in
our just call by Iris type operators you
can see here one two three the connector
functions and first I call iris then
hundred to row ID to column function
which create I account from row ID
naming it ID then hundred the result is
hundred two
the longer function which makes
horizontal white whiter date set into
longer vertical date set and finally I
put it in the supplied function which
supplied a string column in this case I
want to split the slipper lengths all
slipper widows so as you can see
especially Oh as you can see when
separating column 30 bus is much simpler
than in pandas because in pandas there
is no such function to desert job so
it's that I think it's that just the
difference but this is one of the
feature I like him tidy bus so in my
experience this was a little bit simple
example but in my experience so maybe
and many of you and alls and I think
some of your more experience the tunnels
than I do so maybe you have different
experiences in that case I'm glad to
know more but anyway in my experience
and all offers quick and simple ways to
talk with data like when you do explore
lately data analysis at your hand on
this a hand it's not so suitable for
data pipeline of course there you can do
that and with some tools like at least
italics and or I'll studio server
something like that but basically I'm I
think are is not suited
for death pipeline especially menu when
your dates set and falls in to date and
database third about data visualization
so here I compare ggplot2 in all on
matplotlib in Python
both are libraries to create high
quality glasses and charts unfortunately
as you know interactive plot is not
implemented in ggplot2 but you can draw
cool charts with shipload to simply by
default setting allows that so also
muffled live imported its style into
muscle sleep as you can see here you can
draw this approach to style glass in
even a mudflows - oops sorry
so ggplot2 the key feature is I think
aesthetic function I explain later
here's the usage of ggplot2 maybe you've
most of you already know but here it
here shows and how it works first you
specify data to plot with GG plot
function here and then we in the plot
function you call aesthetic function is
to specify XY a for example to specify X
Y variables and then you need to call
layers functions such as G on point or
GM histogram to create scatter plot or
histograms then you can add some
declaration of functions - for example
to use different color set or to set
x-axis in a log scale so example case
again iris
maybe your boss told you I tell you show
me relationship between sibilings and
Peter lengths buys this is as soon as
possible it's data life of data analyst
but then I try to draw a scatter plot so
how can I do that right
he's again in our using ggplot2 and left
is in pandas so first I call iris like I
did in the data wrong ring in so now on
I correct in the ggplot function then
the second argument of the plot function
I call aesthetic function to specify x
and y and grouping for coloring so this
color equals fit species means that I
color each data point based on each
species and then V is plus knock I call
Jian point layer function to plot
scatter to make a scatter plot so as you
can see color grouping is very different
in each plot to on mottrot liebe dich
pottery to is much simpler this is
another feature I like so unfortunately
ggplot2 is not perfect because as I
mentioned interactive visualization is
not implemented but you still have
choice totally if you use Python you
have many
Collective protein libraries like
bouquet on Seabourn so totally does
almost a same thing and one advantage Oh
totally is that the plotly you can is
closely both in our on Python and as you
can see here the plot Li is as simple as
easy plot to two years so in my
experience all provides strong and
efficient ways to draw glass like and
when you do exploratory data analysis
and you create nice chart for
presentations or maybe for documents but
I didn't explain but them in my
experience I think always not
necessarily the best option for
dashboard for example and if I do that
dashboard to share with my marketing
team
I choose case by case and some other
cases this is a brief overview about
machine learning Big Data and don't
natural language processing for machine
learning all on pison have many options
but as you can see some of them are
interface it to Python implementation
now you can use callous and tensorflow
in all but and balconies after your
Python so technically and you use Python
when you use colors and tensorflow
in all and also for big data and natural
language processing Tyson has more
options on our does
so it selected ally but conclusion this
is one of the most asked and I also
asked so I'm all versus pison or which
is better or which should I use
I've been asked and here I cited a
Bolivian answer by hard Rebecca do you
know him he is a creator and developer
of Thai diverse package and in an
interview he answered all on pison
exists independently and oh sorry
and both awesome in different ways all
is weird language but it is weird for
good reasons
use whatever makes you happy I totally
agree with him so you can use any tools
languages which makes you or your police
or your customers happy but still I
recommend you to be bilingual because it
enhances your current data analysis
skills in Python for example in when you
do explore data or you make a fine chart
for your presentation also it could
enhance your career paths in death
science if you use a lon Pisan bolt you
can interact with both communities and
learning new things is just fun I think
it's most important because I every day
learn new things in Allen Python and it
stimulates me every time so let's start
learning all on enjoy thank you no thank
you
um are there any questions we have
around five minutes what's what's your
experience as far as deploying the
dashboard
have you found like our and Shai need to
be easier than the tools available in
Python or mmm-hmm what what's your
experience with that yes I try to use
shiny you know a company but the IT team
has some their own regulation so I
cannot install the shiny into my server
so I had to use some other - Zhang no oh
no Python it's a code tableau I I I
think it it was good choice because
marketing people sometimes don't have
any data literacy in the worst case so I
make I try to make sure that everyone
can use dashboard by themselves I
thanks for the talk more of a suggestion
than a question I really like the ideas
of grammar of graphics and I recently
found the idea Python library I don't
know if anybody else knows it or uses it
which kind of implements a very nice
interface to grammar of graphics style
plotting in Python so if you don't know
that yet it's well worth checking out
it's also interactive and for the
browser browser and whatnot oh think um
I didn't know that so I'll check it
later thank you
well maybe one question from my side you
showed the difference between tidy data
and not tidy data it seems that our is
more into the structure of tidy data we
often worth pies and pandas and such on
try to have every feature in a separate
column is there any reason do you think
there's a conceptual difference in
working with it it's a good question and
also on its the area I need to learn but
I think when you great tidy data I
showed and you can easily calculate the
things more non tidy data but on the
other hand there are some good points
about non tidy data so I think it's
totally depends on your goal I mean know
what do you want to do so you can choose
both way thank you for the talk and can
you tell us a little bit about your
experience regarding the performance
between our and Python all so there is
there's an old wall telling that arisen
that performing this Python especially
the pandas library what's your
experience what's your take on with that
okay honestly speaking I usually don't
use not so huge dataset so I usually
don't feel much difference between them
but if you need to use for example 10
gigabyte or 100 gigabyte did set maybe
I'm using Python could outperform owl
because as you know and I'll impulse all
of the data in the memory
there are no further questions please
think thank the speaker again thank you
very much
[Music]